these are the video clips that can
change an election if it's a legitimate
rape the opposition research that
uncovers these indelible moments is now
a big business I think we're at over 50
races that we delivered material on to
all of our clients meet Joe pounder
president of America rising LLC these
turned political research into a big
commodity we work with 30 different
conservative and Republican
organizations providing them the
research they need and we really go
where the marketplaces teams of
researchers analyst video trackers and
operatives have one goal to equip
Republican candidates with the best most
damning information available about
their opponents and it's all at their
fingertips while reaching voters through
television ads is important in the
modern campaign you need other tactics
to Tim Miller is the executive director
of America rising pack in pounder lead a
10 million dollar operation put together
by former romney 2012 aides Democrats
had the more lethal opposition research
operations last cycle America rising LLC
in America rising pack were deployed as
the fix our candidates got really hurt
by opposition research finds by
Democrats most famously in the
presidential election you saw the Bain
Capital issue that really hurt Mitt
Romney foundered Miller are already
having an impact one example they caught
on tape Iowa Democrat Bruce Braley
criticizing GOP senator chuck grassley
the well-liked Dean of the state's
congressional delegation a farmer from
Iowa who never went to law school miller
runs the super pac side of the operation
it's focused on rapid response and it's
backed by donors like hedge fund
billionaire ken griffin and linda
mcmahon the professional wrestling
magnet pounders domain run as an LLC has
paying clients ranging from candidates
the outside groups like American
Crossroads they've dropped as much as
seven figures for research books video
databases and instant
dates as a for-profit the company is
free to coordinate directly with any
campaign presidential teams should be
here young 20-somethings form the
backbone of America rising over 20
trackers are deployed across the country
stalking Democratic candidates when you
go into a house race for a Senate race
there is no equivalent of Bloomberg in
these states so we have to create it we
have to get the video constantly from
the field cataloging every move of every
major 2014 candidate and keeping a close
eye on the big target for 2016 Hillary
Clinton but they're not stopping there
they're now launching a new operation to
track top Democratic donors like
billionaire environmentalist Tom Steyer
the group hopes to become the permanent
centralized research database for the
party with an archive of democratic gas
that can be used in cycle after cycle I
will stab nothing to try and get a check
from you Democrats have taken notice in
business it's good one year ago we're in
apartments down the street from here
with about six people right now we've
got over 60 people all across the
country